i think healthcare and education
are the fundamental building blocks to
the america that i want to see
[Music]
i'm matt mccambridge i'm the co-founder
and the ceo at eden health
we provide a concierge doctor for every
person and we mean by that is
integrating all the navigation
care coordination advocacy complexity of
navigating the health care system
directly with medical providers
[Music]
when i was about 10 years old i watched
my sister at the age of 14
go through four years of really
traumatic medical experiences
she went to the er after volleyball
practice with anaphylactic
shock they kicked off four years of
going to special types of specialists
about 70 in total
where nobody you know would have read
our case ahead of time
nobody would coordinate the care they'd
do all the same tests and then very
luckily about four years in we found a
primary care provider who was early in
her career coordinated
her care got her the right medication
and she was able to grow out of that
issue so what i think about medicine i
think about that almost
nirvana of health care at the very end
right up next to
the worst version of the health care
system as well and we wanted to provide
that amazing health care experience to
everybody
[Music]
i never really woke up when i was a kid
thinking oh man i want to be a ceo of a
company
but i found something that was connected
to my personal life that was connected
to
how i perceived the world and said that
that's the thing i really want to focus
on
if you want to wake up every day and
fight through things that are difficult
and build the organization and you know
when you get tired figure out how do you
keep working you have to be obsessed
with the problem often you'll hear
people
maybe say that that's not a good idea or
you know you won't get the investment
that you wanted
i think that having grit through that
period of time having the strength to
say no i have convictions
in what i think is right and being able
to build that
further is really essential
you